Sandra laya es licenciada en educación
con posgrado y ejerce desde hace 15 años
la docencia su sueldo no llega a los 20
dólares mensuales en un país en el que
la canasta básica ronda los 500 para
obtener más dinero da clases
particulares a unos 20 niños en esta
escuela improvisada nosotros estudiamos
para tener una mejor calidad de vida una
profesión
este mejor preparado Pero ahora vender
helado costura peluquería es lo que
realmente le daría a un docente para
cubrir algunas necesidades no todas
desde el pasado 9 de enero Sandra se ha
unido a las protestas de calle para
exigir un salario digno no tiene miedo a
ser despedida dice no tener Nada que
perder
vestuario no tenemos Zapatos o sea nada
nos cubre ya por Venezuela al frente de
las protestas de educadores del sector
público ha estado Elsa Castillo una
dirigente sindical con 30 años de
servicio pese a sufrir asedio y
persecución ha recorrido todo el país
juntando fuerzas para continuar la
protesta el evento más más duro fue
cuando nos bajaron de un carro que eso
lo denuncié en su oportunidad
en agosto cuando nos bajaron de un carro
a punta de pistola y nos hicieron
amenazas
el último año el Bolívar pasó de 5 a 25
bolívares por dólar y el salario de los
trabajadores se convirtió en el más bajo
de América Latina incluso por debajo de
Haití Honduras y Cuba pero según este
economista indexar el sueldo mínimo a la
canasta básica como piden los maestros
no es factible la única manera de que el
salario real se incremente de manera
sostenibles que hay aumentos de
productividad Y que además logres
controlar la inflación mientras tengas
inflaciones de 440 por ciento No hay
manera que los aumentos salariales sean
por encima de la inflación en medio de
las masivas protestas la asamblea
nacional aprobó una ley que permitiría
bachilleres ejercer como docentes en
sustitución de los maestros
Sandra no está de acuerdo con la medida
como tampoco lo está contener que
regresar a casa caminando porque el
dinero no le alcanza para el transporte